e aí
se vocês sabiam que cerca de sessenta
por cento do viagra vendido no para
jovens de até 26 anos e
e isso é comprovado por pesquisas
recentes em balcão de farmácia e quando
a gente tem essa informação a gente
pensa primeiro né não são os idosos que
estão tomando viagra na sua maioria
e em segundo porque quem jovem que ainda
não tem problema de ereção quer dizer
talvez tenha problema de ereção demais
né tá tomando viagra
oi e aí eu penso provavelmente ele está
buscando uma performance pornográfica
porque quando ele se interessou pelo
assunto né e não encontrou nem na
família nem na escola informação boa mas
encontrou de fácil acesso na internet
urgente de se relacionar sexualmente
esse é um modelo é uma forma e acredito
nisso o que não foi contado para esse
jovem é que ali pode haver sexo
explícito mas não tem sexo de qualidade
não é sexo bom porque não envolve essa
parte do corpo não envolve o emocional
não se beija não se abraço coração não
encosta com o coração não se beija o
pescoço não importa
e ali as pessoas estão sendo vistas como
objetos e
é tanta mulher que já é uma coisa
clássica mas o homem também inclusive o
homem ele está resumido a um pênis ereto
é muitas vezes o rosto dele nem aparece
no vídeo ou seja um esse homem pensa
assim eu não for para me interessa não
sou nada
e esse cara tá tentando seguir dogmas
machista né primeiro o homem sempre tem
que ter e se relacionar isso dar essa
insistência dos homens né esse assédio
constante se por um lado as mulheres não
podem andar em paz nas ruas sem serem
assediadas por outro lado os homens vão
se tornar especialistas em rejeição e
vão acumulando a frustração e raiva né a
cada nova tentativa insistindo com a
mesma mulher ou insistindo com outras
mulheres e fazer esse papel
o segundo o homem não pode falhar né não
pode de forma nenhuma não cumpriu o seu
dever acontece que essa tal dessa
brochada ela não é uma doença não é
assim olha eu quero me relacionar com
meu que ele ficou tarde não não é o
pênis é parte do corpo ea linguagem
corporal é a linguagem emocional ali
alguma coisa emocional que o cara não tá
querendo entrar em contato
é nesse momento ele tá desvalorizando o
seu emocional ou em outras palavras tá
desvalorizando o seu feminino porque sim
os homens têm feminino assim como as
mulheres têm masculina todos nós temos
masculino e feminino e isso é uma
realidade comprovada tanto pela medicina
quanto pela psicologia anatomicamente
por exemplo o clitóris é um pernilzinho
é o pênis da mulher é os homens têm
mamas são capazes de produzir e
hormonalmente né nós produzimos os
homens produzem hormônios femininos as
mulheres produzem hormônios masculinos
cognitivamente o jeito que a gente
entende o mundo mas o cérebro de todos
nós é dividido em dois hemisférios
masculino e feminino o masculino é mais
racional ele divide com a carola as
coisas mais universo feminino é o único
capaz de entendimento porque ele que da
noção de todo né se numa cena o
masculino ele vê as proporções os
tamanhos mas o feminino da a nossa
a novidade e também nas formas de gordo
sexual humano a uma forma masculina e
uma feminina e eu não tô falando de
homem e mulher os dois são acessíveis a
todos nós o gozo e masculino é o gozo
verbal visual é aquilo que me sinta tem
nome lugar a gente deu corpo como objeto
mesmo dividir em partes então a coxa
bunda o bife a boca os olhos seja o que
for a parte do corpo que necessita eo
gozo feminino é o que nos dá essa um
gozo como um todo é um gozo inominável é
o gozo de pessoa para pessoa onde
interessa a pessoa com que eu tô me
relacionando a história é o gol de
emocional
oi e aí segundo que dá uma relação de
maior qualidade desde quando a gente
acha que uma relação foi boa não é
porque teve muito a cristo muito é
porque houve um envolvimento emocional é
nesse ponto que a pornografia fica só no
bolso masculino espremendo mais caldo da
mesma fruta né e é por isso que se
relaciona se relaciona que continue
satisfeito
e é uma coisa do machismo mesmo
valorizado demasiadamente o masculino e
desvalorizar o feminino em todas as
distâncias o de todos nós
e eu acho que assim a escada armadilha
que prende o homem preso ao machismo é a
suposição que o machismo e beneficia e
eu tô aqui hoje para jogar luz sobre
isso que ainda tá invisível com dois
pontos que eu procuro trabalhar como eu
achei um pedido para os homens e como
algumas mulheres e alguns momentos aqui
também que atitudes machista eu não
quero lá dizer que nem o fato de tomate
não permitir que as mulheres e todos os
homens em atitudes machistas e que a
obra isso é claro a gente precisa jogar
luz sobre o que está obscuro
o vídeo ponto onde o machismo mais
prejudica os homens é na dificuldade que
ele queria dos homens amarem o amor é
fundamental para humano amor e humano
ser amor e ser humano é praticamente
sinônimo eu já as crianças provam isso
constantemente é inclusive isso que a
gente faz que são as palavras foi
desenvolvido por uma sociedade que se
solidarizou mais o que os outros animais
a gente parou de brigar para o
território fêmea pode se aproximar
desenvolver as palavras e criou história
e isso que a gente tá fazendo aqui então
quando o machismo cria uma uma
dificuldade de amar porque para a gente
amar é pedir a gente se entregar ao
sentimento a gente precisa depende de
alguma forma a gente só contar com o
controle é porque que os faz querem
saber exatamente onde estão os filhos
todo momento porque você fez meu filho
eles vão sofrer muito então a questão é
que o machismo dificulta toda todo o
sentimento de todas as emoções o que é
um conceito assim a emoção sempre
acontecem editável a gente pode conter o
sentimento da emoção agora uma
e sempre acontece se a gente não sente
não presta ela vir outra coisa ela vira
doença ela vira problema psicológico ea
incompetência do homem expressar emoção
lidar com ela é gritante que dia aparece
toda semana infelizmente às vezes
diariamente homens que em crises
emocionais intensas como é que
atrocidades por exemplo quando termina
uma relação e precisa ligar para o monte
de emoção o cara mata a ex-mulher
o país companheira marcar os seus filhos
mata a si mesmo muitas vezes mostrando a
incompetência a desestruturação dele
numa crise emocional eu tenho um fato
que eu coloquei uma entrevista da hebe
de bonafini aí figura acima é a líder
das mães da praça de maio é um grupo de
mulheres que durante a ditadura
argentina se organizou porque sumiu da
noite dias sumiram vários jovens pelos
pelo regime militar
e aí foram dados como desaparecidos as
mães não se conformaram foram para rua
porque essa frase de marca em frente o
governo um cartazes lá ela se conheceram
ela se uniram lutaram contra polícia
lutará contra o governo quiser um
movimento que ganhou fama mundial tanto
que elas estavam sendo entrevistada pela
revista caros amigos eu tava lendo essa
entrevista em dado momento o repórter
perguntou e os maridos de você ela falou
nossos maridos todos morreram no espaço
de cinco anos depois que nossa filha
linda
e eu quero que ela tá isso como um olhar
de cientista e vai ver nisso tudo de
casa não tá falando você tenta casais tá
e se você imaginar a demanda emocional
do filho de aparecida era pior que o
filho morto que eu fiz um morto e teve o
corpo enterra o creme aí só isso tem um
filho agora desaparecido pode aparecer a
qualquer momento pode estar presos sendo
torturados sofrendo é uma agonia
constante as mulheres transferir ligar
para suas emoções elas se transformaram
essa dor e coragem e ganharam fama
mundial os homens ficaram em casa
sucumbindo e morreram todos entupido e
todas as suas emoções isso mexe comigo
porque eu tenho entendimento eu quero
fazer da minha voz a voz desses homens
que não falaram perguntar o que matou o
solo
e não foi o fato do filho dele primeiro
o que as mães estão vivas
e foi uma criação machista
e botões incompetência ligar fazer uma
forma
oi tá mais do que na hora da gente
perceber e a gente fazer a nossa
revolução contra o machismo a por nós
homens pelos nossos filhos pelos nossos
netos têm um mundo menos machista digo
assim a gente só vai machista assinassem
marca mas hoje eu consigo ser menos um
artista do que eu era ontem e amanhã
quem sabe eu sou menos machista
é do que eu passei do ovo
o outro ponto onde que o machismo
prejudica os homens a questão da
dominância da esfera doméstica e da
esfera social assim você pegar um século
atrás de 1920 a mulher dominava
esperando a esperar doméstico o ambiente
doméstico o homem social ao longo deste
último século a mulher veio conquistando
espera social passos largos falta alguma
coisa que valência salarial esquece mas
ela continua lutando mas a mulher tá na
política a mulher tava cantando nas
empresas a mulher é a fita a mulher tá
dirigindo metade dos veículos que estão
nas ruas agora os homens conquistaram o
ambiente doméstico nessa mesma proporção
da assim no século passado a mulher
passava na mão do pai se a mão do marido
o homem eu passava na mão da mãe para
mão da esposa hoje em dia todo pai toda
mãe dizia filha você tem que trabalhar
tem que estudar trabalhar de forma a não
depender de nenhum homem no futuro agora
as mães e os pais são dizendo meu filho
você precisa aprender a lavar louça
precisa aprender a rede enfeitar um
banheiro para não ter
o número futuro não é o dia das mães
continua dando mais infertile para
filhas do que possível curso da da
manutenção da casa né isso é injusto com
a menina mas é justo para o menino
também que baixo no banana esse menino
mimado me mais esse menino essa posição
de que a vantagem não é depois ele vai
pagar com juros e correção monetária
essa folga né eu percebi que atitude
dessa mãe é uma atitude machista como as
vezes é difícil perceber que a mulher
tem atitude machista a eu sou o pai de
menino e teu pai de menina e procura da
tanto a do trabalho para o estudo para
os dois como para casa aprenda a
cozinhar tem técnica para lavar louça né
não é que tem que lavar primeiro o como
diz assim é apaixonada por ele era
maravilhoso até que ele lavou o primeiro
a frigideira e depois do talleres quer
dizer né e tu é
o outro passar para os dois agora como o
pai de filho de filha também que é uma
questão que é um ponto extremo de
violência do machismo né minha filha
ficou moça e a gente tem que ficar olha
que tomar cuidado onde anda procurar
sempre ficar com amiga porque
infelizmente então tipo de violência
extrema e é isso que você corre perigo e
que você quer ser livre andar por aí
precisa saber agora pro meu filho também
preciso falar filha porque você vive em
uma sociedade machista e você tiver
usando a camiseta errada no lugar errado
você pode ser linchado por uma
bandeirola essa cena de homem lixando o
homem foi criado outro time ou por
motivos banais é a massa de expressão do
machismo sem machismo e fica claro como
isso prejudica o sono
a guerra é a máxima expressão do
machismo e não é à toa que guerra é
sinônimo de homem matando um homem e
violentando mulher
é nesse ponto eu quero dizer o que que é
a inserção da mulher nesses papéis de
filme hollywoodiano tem sempre o mesmo
roteiro de violência né violência
justificada por violência vingança e vai
matando sair matando todo mundo as
mulheres estão ganhando papéis nesses
filmes totalmente e massa choca o que é
isso e revolução é essa
a perceber que o machismo contemporâneo
muito habilmente deixar vocês querem os
mesmos dentes então tá aqui o mesmo
direito de ser macho e com isso o
machismo está crescendo tem mel machismo
que ainda nem tá sendo visto como
machismo e não é só nesses filmes era
postura de algumas mulheres de alguns
momentos eu detesto generalizar mas no
trânsito muitas vezes dirigindo só essa
chover e passando por cima de do
pedestre não respeita dirigindo empresa
veja o mundo com adicionando mais
machista um controle novo lugar para
seguir o teu machismo se alimenta da
guerra entre o sexo da guerra entre os
géneros desde o princípio e se o
marxismo clássico é o homem ea primeira
mulher ele não vai se resolver com a
mulher e o primeiro homem
e somente com a união dos gêneros
o que a gente vai conseguir superar o
machismo uma a luta contra o machismo
não é uma luta das mulheres contra os
homens é uma luta de homens e mulheres
que não concordam com o machismo contra
o machismo remoção dos homens
automatismo ela vai ser totalmente
diferente das mulheres não tem sentido a
gente ir para rua com o panfleto em
cartaz em tecido a gente tem má cueca
como elas queimaram o sutiã continua é
aí que o machismo nos oprime
em nenhuma sociedade por mais machista
que seja mesmo aquelas muçulmanos
islâmicos radicais que a mulher eu já
pública ninguém impede ela de sofrer ela
fica melhor mas sofre em uma sociedade
machista de mulher que a mulher não
chora eu percebi tu a nossa revolução
vai ser a interna é pessoal e ela já tá
acontecendo tá bonito de ver ela tá
acontecendo na postura dos novos pais
que estão criando seus filhos de uma
forma muito diferente das gerações
anteriores
é importante ressaltar amor e
compreensão é importante mas ele também
é importante tá serrando a mão um pouco
e não tem uma forma de atenção muito
especial nessa gerações anteriores 0
limite de baixo churra a gente se achar
um novo jeito mais precisa da língua ea
revolução dos homens está acontecendo em
centenas de grupos de terapia de homens
que estão acontecendo no brasil e no
mundo por um sentimento parte superior
que chama ter a pizza a gente perde uma
pizzaria e os homens ficam nas mesas
conversando e a gente vai faz ciência de
alguns amigos brinca e depois se reúne e
compatível que sentiu o que se constata
aqui muitos homens dizem olha acontecido
cometer violência que deixei de fazer
uma besteira na minha vida eu tô aqui
tem que lugar para conversar
oi oi príncipe aqui assim valorizam
nosso feminino não vai prejudicar o
nosso masculino um não é contra o outro
é complementar ao outro valorizar nossos
feminino a equilibrar o nosso masculino
e se acha só dessa masculinidade tóxica
é uma comunidade de todos nós homens e
mulheres ela tá toca porque tá demais
bom então ela vai se tornar menos tóxica
mais equilibrada
e é percebi aqui são os gêneros a mesma
espécie o que possui sua uh vai ser
feito ao outro se prejudicar um tá se
dando um tiro no pé
olá tudo cada um com seus motivos que
não cabe às mulheres fazer a revolução
dos alunos cabe a nós fazer a nossa
revolução contra o machismo elas estão
fazendo a delas estamos muito bem
o junto lutando contra o machismo a
gente vai conseguir superar essa fase
machista da humanidade e
e aí